foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
new video I want to discuss a few things
in regards to the making of House of the
dragon's second season as you all know
HBO as well as its creators are now
working on the follow-up of House of the
dragon's incredibly successful for our
season in fact I don't know how many of
you know this or not but House of the
Dragon recently won the Golden Globe for
the best drama series Once Again George
RR Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire
universe is right back where it belongs
as one of the best shows on television
now before we do go any further I want
to remind everyone that I will be
announcing the winner of my giveaway at
the end of this video as I mentioned
last week I am giving away the First
full season of House of the Dragon so
make sure you watch the whole video to
see who won I also want to let all of
you know about this amazing new offer I
want to thank the sponsor of today's
video brilliant brilliant is an
Interactive Learning tool that uses a
Hands-On approach to teach you a wide
range of stem Concepts like math science
and computer science it has been perfect
for me as a Hands-On learner the most
efficient way to learn is interactively
while testing yourself along the way
brilliant offers simulations to
manipulate in quizzes to master any new
subject you can find everything on
brilliant from the foundations of math
all the way up to college level content
such as cosmology and quantum mechanics
and there are new exclusive lessons
added each month brilliant is the best
way to learn something new every day and
learning a little every day can have a
huge impact on your brain's Health and
Longevity I like to spend 30 minutes on
brilliant in the mornings while I drink
my coffee it is a much more productive
way to stimulate my brain and get ready
for the day rather than scrolling
through social media now the best part
is you don't have to spend a fortune or
four years in a classroom either the
first 200 people to sign up with my link
brilliant.org talking Thrones will get
20 off an annual premium subscription
don't miss out on this amazing offer
once again I would like to thank
brilliant for sponsoring today's video
in recent interviews Summer House of the
Dragons actors have made some very
exciting announcements about the show
and its new season for those of you who
don't know House of the Dragon will
begin filming its second season in March
that's only one and a half months away
now as soon as filming does begin we
will start to see lots of photos and
videos leak out from the sets when that
happens it will start to become very
easy to see what will be happening in
the new season and I will be here making
videos on everything that happens in the
off season every step of the way the
same as I did during the seasons of Game
of Thrones as well as the first season
of House of the Dragon so make sure you
subscribe now if you want to stay up to
date on everything that is happening
with every Game of Thrones show like
also the dragon the Jon Snow show The
Duncan egg series as well as George RR
Martin's The Winds of Winter there is a
lot of stuff happening in The Song of
Ice and Fire fandom that you won't want
to miss now in a recent interview with
Entertainment Weekly House of the Dragon
actor Tom glencarni said he's for aegon
to cause more havoc and House of the
dragon's second season he said House of
the Dragons actors and actresses are
already getting their bodies ready for
the strenuous demands of the new season
now that the dance of the Dragons has
officially started after the death of
lucari's valerion it sounds like life in
Westeros is about to become very
exciting and dangerous in The Following
season during Game of Thrones first ever
official fan convention The House of the
Dragon actor also said I'm looking
forward to having aegon have a lot more
meat to get his teeth stuck into and to
cause more Havoc really and to throw a
spanner in the works which he does so
well now that viserys is dead Ian Dagon
is the new king of Westeros House of the
Dragon will shift a lot of its focus on
his character For Better or Worse
filming on the second season is
confirmed to start in March Glenn
Kearney mentioned and there's physical
work to be done by the actors like I
said we will now see these characters in
battle now that the dance of the Dragons
has begun now he also said he hopes
audiences won't be so fast to judge him
though he admits it's already not
looking good so it does sound like we
will see a different side of aegon but
it might not be enough for fans to start
standing behind him in another recent
article House of the Dragon actor Ewan
Mitchell also known as aemond one eye
Targaryen said they will be filming for
roughly eight months like I said HBO
will begin filming House of the Dragon
in March and that's when we should start
seeing a lot of photos and videos leak
out from the sets for the next eight
months and that will lead up to the
release of their first official teasers
and trailers for their second season
although we are in the off season right
now things are about to get very
exciting once filming begins like I said
that's when we will start to learn what
will be happening in all of the
different scenes throughout the season
now during this same interview Ewan
Mitchell gave us a glimpse of what we
can expect to see when asked about
what's next for his character Amon
Targaryen said so much of this season
sees the family's World balance on a
knife's edge all it's gonna take is for
a shove from either side to draw blood I
guess aemond is the guy who's started
the domino effect that'll lead to the
dance of the dragons and if season 1 was
about seeing aemon getting warmed up
season two is an all-out War like I've
said before I believe the second season
of House of the Dragon will be far
better than the first this stage is now
set we know all the players the time
jumps are over and the battle for the
Iron Throne is only getting started make
sure you subscribe because there's about
to be a lot more news heading your way
now I want to announce the winner of my
new giveaway last week I said I would be
giving away the First full season of
House of the Dragon for one of my
subscribers in that name who was
randomly selected is Destiny white all
you gotta do is make sure you send me an
email verifying that it's you then I
will send you the first season of House
of the Dragon you can find my email down
below in the description of this video
once again I want to thank everyone who
does watch my videos I will be doing
another giveaway very soon as always I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
thank you